yeah i saw you just signed an artist but
um
the the the take hey kid was supposed to
sign with you right so the whole story
with that right is i met tk through
puya's dj marcus right he's like yo
there's this artist from texas blaze
blase lit puts me in contact with my
[ __ ] with him he shows me the video so
i'm like yo you're hot like this is hot
bro like i know my [ __ ] i've called out
multiple [ __ ] artists
so he had gone somewhere i didn't know
he was on the run i didn't know [ __ ] yes
i'm like all right cool i'm gonna sign
you blah blah
and literally he called me a few days
he's like yo i'm gonna come to miami i'm
like okay cool i'll buy your ticket let
me know he's somewhere up north or some
[ __ ]
so the day before i buy his ticket
literally he gets picked up by i think
was the us marshalls or some [ __ ]
yeah and then someone from his camp
sends me the video he's like yo taking
once you dropped this video
and that's how the race ended up on my
youtube but take it was going to kind of
miami and i was going to sign take it
and that's what not just some [ __ ] you
just like part of buffet boys i mean
yeah yeah
so
that's that's a crazy story man so
that's how that ended up on your youtube
page yeah did you ever actually meet him
in person never when he was gonna fight
in miami i was gonna meet him he got
picked up by the marshalls
wow
and then you upload the video the video
goes [ __ ] crazy
do you guys still talk
i haven't talked to him in so long
yeah not not because of my choice right
just because other people plus it's not
like you guys are like super close
yeah